more than a million creditors could be
affected by the FTX Fallout in its
chapter 11 bankruptcy filing last week
FTX indicated that it had more than a
hundred thousand creditors claiming this
case in its updated filing on Tuesday
the company cited new estimates as set
forth
in the debtors petitions there are more
than there are over a hundred thousand
creditors in these chapter 11 cases in
fact there could be more than one
million creditors in these chapter 11
cases the updated Court filing says
usually in such cases debtors are
required to provide a list and with
names and addresses of the top 20
unsecured creditors but given the
large-scale FTX debts The Firm intends
to provide a list of top 50 creditors by
Friday during the weekend FTX was also
hit by a hacking attack which resulted
in a theft of 400 million dollars worth
of tokens just accidentally just
happened this week random uh situation
that obviously it's very random with
this company and now the lawsuit is
tying in names like Brady Steph Curry
Gizelle Shaq and a bunch of other guys
that are part of this lawsuit but the
part that was interesting was the mom's
article that she wrote for Stanford in
2013 scene Sam bankman Freed's Professor
mother penned 2013 essay shredding
philosophy of personal responsibility so
you can tell she's a big Iron ran person
if you want to go a little lower go a
little lower here to the article so the
mothers are bringing a Founder Pharmacy
of the new bankrupt FTX company Stanford
law professor Penny 2013 arguing that it
is time for Americans to ditch the
philosophy of personal responsibility
well trust me your son ditched it
Barbara freed who just resigned from the
Democratic Super PAC mined the Gap as
the board of directors chairperson pende
2013 essay in the Boston Review titled
Beyond blame which argued in favor of
harm reduction policies
like Rehabilitation over incarceration
the philosophy personal responsibility
has ruined criminal criminal justice and
economic policy it's time to move past
blame public reactions to wrongdoings
have been studied most extensively and
the context of crime researchers have
found that people uh evaluations of
serious wrongfulness very significantly
cross-social conditions in individuals
tellingly the more information people
have uh about the context of the crime
the person who committed it and the
circumstances he or she came from the
more nuanced are their views of moral
responsibility yesterday you're on Fox I
think the question was being asked I
don't know if it was yesterday maybe
like nine days ago or so it could have
been yesterday and question was asked
about what's going on and he said listen
I just want us to follow the law what is
the law that we have you know if people
are breaking the law you know we got to
do something about it these guys are
stealing and getting away with it we
ought to do something about it what do
you think about what's going on right
now with FTX where AI whose company was
valued at 32 billion when you raised 2
billion dollars net worth 16 billion
dollars takes the company from 32 to
zero
there's nothing new Under the Sun I mean
Enron
differences you know Enron was in the
energy space and we all knew that
underneath all of this thing was a thing
that we all desperately needed it was
energy you know what's under this thing
the uh
all I see is Hope and Faith and a notion
that something is going to be worth more
today than it was yesterday I don't
understand what the asset is really
so you know in
when there's nothing tangible to point
to
you know I mean I the thing about this
story that interests me is you know
what's what's Tom Brady thinking today
and what what's what's Bill Clinton
thinking right when you see that clip of
him sitting there next to this guy in
cargo shorts who's clearly on the
Spectrum just babbling nonsense the
number of credible people who who sat
next to this guy that's David Rubinstein
from Carlisle group he's going to be on
the podcast in a couple weeks what four
billion dollars I guess [ __ ] in sitting
there not [ __ ] there he's sitting
there with shorts yeah it's like hey
what's up David now look on the one hand
to our earlier point I I don't want my
own cognitive dissonance to look at this
guy and conclude that you know he's an
asshat because he he's jittery and he
wears shorts and he's got a funny
haircut whatever
what's really going on what's what's
really under a collapse of a 32 billion
dollar company is
beyond my pay grade other than a lot of
people
uh propped this guy up a lot of people
for whatever reason said yeah him
yeah yeah let's do that and uh and the
next thing you know it's collapsing
under its own weight
so I mean it's a horrible thing to watch
but it's funny what you said about Fox I
was on there a month ago and they had a
live audience and somebody asked me what
would you do if you were president like
what what one thing would you do
and uh you know that's the one yeah
that's the one yeah yeah I said well for
starters let's let's enforce the laws on
the books because if you don't do that
then this 32 billion dollar story is
going to actually rhyme really easily
with the videotapes of Smash and grabs
all over the place
in the sense that we need to see a
consequence for this and when you don't
see a consequence you know when when
you're shown a border that's clearly
insecure
when you're shown people falling from
the sky during a withdrawal from a place
like Afghanistan that was clearly
botched you know when you can see
clearly the fact of a thing and then
you're told definitively that it's
something else
then then you really do have a level of
cognitive dissonance that goes Way
Beyond oh the Dirty Jobs guy used to
sing the Opera and it goes back to the
very first thing we were talking about
this bag is not a toy don't stick your
finger in the fan and you find yourself
looking at the other people in the room
going are you kidding me
are you so you're really going to tell
me not to stick my finger in a fan are
you kidding me you're really going to
tell me that I should put my retirement
money into a pension plan that's going
to invest heavily in a company
based on that guy
really
so I it for me it it all comes back to
the absurdity of being told that the bag
is not a toy
this kid right you're going to tell me
with a straight face that this kid ought
to be running a 32 billion dollar
company you're going to print all right
you're in charge of a newspaper and
you're gonna print
an article from a woman who says what we
need in our country right now is less
personal responsibility that's his mom
that's his mom right so look things are
things will fall into place things will
start to make sense but the bigger
question is what what's the publisher
thinking why what who would print an
article like that why would you do that
you know you mentioned that he's clearly
on the Spectrum no apparently like this
is what you're well can you go to that
picture with the shorts this kid's been
built up for years 30 under 30 right so
for me one of the cues on being on the
spectrum is like your ability or your
inability to take social cues okay so
like you look at a picture like this
you're sitting down with a full-on
billionaire doing an interview for
Bloomberg all right we're familiar with
Mark Zuckerberg and he shows up in a
T-shirt and what have you he's built up
a legitimate business whether it's
controversial now we can have a whole
discussion about here's this kid
shows up looking like this like just
rolled up out of bed at what point in
your life
do you say yep I'm just going to show up
in sweatpants cut off socks slippers
frazzled hair the amount of disrespect
it takes
to show up to an interview like this
with a credible businessman to me is
like a Telltale sign of of course
something was off yeah okay like the
Zuckerberg thing all right t-shirt you
know that's you know Silicon Valley but
to try to pull off this look not taking
social media he's he's it's not even
you're you want that from the that's
what your expectation of this guy's he's
not going to give it to you this is not
a guy that sees himself dude his
girlfriend's father was the ex-sec
chairman that this there's so much stuff
with this guy that people don't even
know about what he was tied to like the
amount of protection this guy had that
you know but but going back to it you
know there's a picture of him if you can
pull up him with Bill Clinton Tony Blair
and Bill Clinton on the same stage with
this guy I don't know if you've seen
that picture now that's really yeah yeah
that's what I was talking about yeah
that's the weird one that's when you see
something like that you're like what the
hell is going on here right I mean I
understand David Rubinstein you want to
come in and say hey I'm a bigger deal
than you fine that's Bill Clinton Tony
Blair look at the way he's dressed
I'm totally with you it's disrespectful
but but forget let's forget that part
let's just say okay fine so this is your
style no problem fine the the paper
trail mom says let's avoid personal
responsibility it's interesting how you
mentioned Enron you know who was one of
our keynote speakers we I put an event
together two months ago at the Diplomat
and I a couple thousand entrepreneurs
show up from around the world
one of our keynote speakers was Andy
fast style you know Andy fast house the
CFO of Enron that went to jail for eight
years yeah I brought him everyone's like
we're still trying to figure out why you
brought this guy here I said I want to
keep you out of jail
because he got up and he says one year I
was the CFO of the year next year this
is my ID to the jail I lived in for
eight years that's the opening speech
okay Andy fastel but can you bring up
that
um what is that but yeah can you
demonstrate she was what uh yeah I just
read that a minute ago can you bring up
the uh Instagram post of the comparison
of uh this versus Lehman's Brothers go
back to the first slide go back all the
way down to the first one okay so
billions of dollars seem to have
disappeared with the collapse of FTX how
does this even happen go to the next one
uh the collapse of FTX was a vaporized
billions of dollars in customers money a
shaking the confidence of Market that
was already in Thrones of a login brutal
downturn okay great go to the next one
okay there are some useful historical
comparisons but none paint a complete
picture simply because cryptos values by
Nature uh derived purely from the
specular opinions that the Traders and
investors willing to buy and sell okay
fine but but watch this one here go to
the next one a big difference
between the implosion of FTX and the
downfall of Lehman Brothers in 2008 it
is shocking Mike when you see the stats
is that Lehman's Brothers had more than
600 billion dollars in assets that while
partially liquid at the time were real
assets and could be recovered in the
aftermath of Lehman's collapse it's 111
000 customers received the 106 billion
dollars they were owed and secured
creditors received full payouts sure
Lehman Brothers Equity investors were
completely wiped up you bought the stock
as will be the investors in FTX but
that's the risk Equity investors assume
when they buy in totally get it I bought
a stock go to the next one what can't be
said in the FTX customers will be made
whole on the billions of dollars
evaporated from accounts in part driven
by customer funds being used with
leveraged by ftx's sister company
Alameda who he was dating the CEO
researched to make up for loss is by
trading liquid tokens according to a
report from Financial Times
FTX had less than one billion dollars on
liquid assets against nine billion on
liabilities compared that to Lehman
Brothers who went bankrupt with 630
billion 639 billion in assets
613. if you compared it to Lima should
have never gone out of business they
just tipped the schedule that's insane
to me when you see this comparison Tom
it is the comparisons are out there and
consequences out there like today is a
very telling day uh we all know who
Elizabeth Holmes is the nice young lady
who took nearly a billion dollars from
investors yes that's correct and put a
Secretary of State on the uh on her
board yeah that's right secretary of
state knows a lot about making uh uh
medicine
um and her Playbook remember she blamed
oh it's my lover uh my CEO Sunny balwani
remember that it was like 48 and she was
like 26.
um and she had that in there but today
today in Superior right there in Santa
Clara County she's being sentenced today
her sentencing hearing is today it might
be happening right now and we're gonna
find out is there another set of laws
for people who are well connected and
can lawyer up or is she going to get the
sentencing that's due and we've seen
during the year waiting for the
sentencing she's had one child and then
got pregnant again and there is a leak
of people close to her that said that
was the plot to get married and then to
have a child and a half
in order to have some sort of an
influence on the court as we come into
the sentencing hearing
true story and you know who he's blaming
he's blaming his the article reads FTX
claims to uh be uh releasing uncensored
sex tape allegedly between disgraced
sandbankment freed and Alameda CEO
Caroline Ellison soon this is a story
that's coming out and he's blaming his
ex-lover for FTX collapse and 32 billion
Auto loss admits he lied about being
moral
we woke westerners Play here's a word he
used a dumb game we woke westerners play
gotta love this guy he just I mean you
read about the scale like you know I won
you know a very inspirational type of a
character toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]